mais d'abord la taxe carbone dans le
monde grandes ambitions petit réalité
mickaël thébault
jourdan c'était le 5 octobre dernier
l'un des plus gros pollueurs de la
planète le canada se décider finalement
à ratifier l'accord de paris conclu au
soir de la cap 21 le premier ministre
justin trudeau annoncé même
l'instauration d'une taxe carbone dès
2018 avec fermeture progressive des
centrales électriques qui fonctionnent
encore au charbon formidable avancée
évidemment pour le climat alors que la
chine l'inde et les états unis avaient
eux aussi déjà ratifié l'accord mais
depuis bien sûr il y a eu la victoire de
donald trump le prochain président
américain et sa proximité avec les
cartel pétrolier avec les
climato-sceptiques de tout poil et
depuis c'est le doute l'inquiétude on
l'a bien senti d'ailleurs lors de la cop
22 à marrakech
alors quel avenir pour cette taxe
carbone peut-on encore y croire
ou doit-on bat d'ores et déjà penser à
une autre forme de taxes
environnementales
eh bien on parle ce soir avec jean marc
jancovici bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
ingénieur consultant spécialiste de la
transition énergétique professeur à
mines paristech et fondateur du cabinet
de conseil carbone 4 j'ai presque tout
dit on va d'abord faire un peu de
pédagogie
jean marc jancovici la taxe carbone pour
être très clair c'est quoi où et quand
at-elle été inventé et qui est censé les
payer où et quand elle était inventé je
ne saurais vous le dire parce que il ya
plusieurs personnes à qui on peut
l'attribuer
le principe est assez simple quand vous
émettez des gaz à effet de serre vous
allez causé un dommage futur à quelque
chose qui n'appartient à personne qui le
climat il ya une seule manière de vous
en empêcher c'est de vous dire de ne pas
le faire il ya deux manières de vous
dire de ne pas le faire c'est soit on
roule interdite réglementairement par
exemple vous oblige à acheter une petite
voiture vous oblige à isoler chez vous
ou bien on dit vous pouvez le faire mais
ça va vous coûter temps et ça c'est le
principe de la taxe carbone c'est donc
une fiscalité une taxe comme toute
fiscalité et dont l'idée est d' être
proportionnelles aux émissions vous
allez occasionnés c'est ça la taxe
carbone alors moi particulier en france
en allemagne en autriche aux états unis
je suis concerné où on parle uniquement
des industries
toute la question est de savoir à qui on
l'appliquait normalement on l'appliqué à
toute entité particuliers ou entreprises
qui émet des gaz à effet de serre
donc je suis par exemple propriétaire
d'un immeuble je suis une foncière dans
mon immeuble j'ai une chaudière à gaz
et bien quand la chaudière à gaz
fonctionne eh bien je vais moi le
propriétaire de l'immeuble payer la taxe
carbone sur le fonctionnement de la
chaudière
c'est un particulier vous avez une
voiture vous utilisez du pétrole pour la
faire avancer ce qui aujourd'hui est pas
bien puisque c'est pollué et à ce moment
on va vous dire ben voilà vous avez émis
du co2 en brûlant du pétrole vous payez
vous êtes un industriel 7 par exemple
arcelormittal saviard haut fourneau qui
aimait plein de co2 et on va vous dire
pas de problème mais quand vous coulez
de la fin quand vous fondez de l'acier
ou fait de l'acier exactement la fonte
et bien vous émettez du co2 sur chaque
tonne de co2 que vous émettez on va vous
taxer de temps donc le principe peut
s'appliquer à absolument n'importe qui
bien évidemment après en démocratie vous
avez le jeu classique qui consiste à
dire tout le monde sauf moi bon alors
justement quelles sont des pays qui l'a
aujourd'hui applique la taxe carbone ou
une taxe carbone redire le pays le plus
emblématique dans le monde pour ça c'est
la suède qui l'a instaurée dès 1991 si
même correct dans le cadre d'une grande
réforme fiscale qui avait fait les
suédois un moment où il avait eu des
gros ennuis part à cause du carbone et
ils ont profité de leur grand coup de
balai fiscale pour mettre en place cette
taxe à un niveau assez élevé puisque
elle est au dessus de 100 euros la tonne
elle doit être à 130 si ma mémoire est
correct la france à une taxe carbone
alors vous connaissez cette blague
classique la droite en a rêvé la gauche
l'a fait et bien c'est exactement ce qui
s'est passé avec la taxe carbone ya eu
un grand débat en 2009 où sarkozy a
essayé de la faire passer
c'était une des mesures du pacte
écologique que j'ai co rédigé avec
nicolas hulot et sarkozy à l'époque
n'ont pas réussi à la faire passer mais
hollande l'a fait passer et elle est
aujourd'hui il faut enlever 1,0 par
rapport aux suédois les suédois sont à
130 nous aujourd'hui on est à 20 donc
c'est un grand différentiel cela étant
quand vous regardez ce que ça représente
il faut savoir qu'une hausse de 50
dollars le baril pour l'automobiliste
c'est à peu près comme si on met une
taxe carbone à 100 euros la tonne de co2
en place or le dollar il monte et
descend de sa part dans mon tout des 102
50 dollars assez souvent sur ces
dernières années
ça n'a pas déplacé de manière
significative
le comportement de mes concitoyens et de
moi même en ce qui concerne la conduite
automobile
donc il faut pas quand même 30 peur et
c'est un des problèmes avec la taxe
carbone c'est qu'en général quand on
voit des chiffres élevés tout le monde
commence à prendre peur d'eux va tous
mourir
en fait non il faut quand même
comprendre que même des chiffres élevés
ça représente une ponction sur le
pouvoir d'achat qui reste très modeste
on s'arrêtera un précisément sur sur le
prix et puis surtout les débats qui qui
tourne autour de ce prix suède france
qui d'autre alors après il ya un certain
nombre je les connais pas tous par coeur
et puis il ya un certain nombre de pays
pour lesquels on a l'habitude de parler
non pas de taxe mais de prix du carbone
en mélangeant un peu de systèmes qu'on a
aussi en europe qui à la fois un système
de fiscalité directe comme ceux que je
viens d'évoquer et un système de
fiscalité indirecte qui ne concerne que
les entreprises qui le fameux système de
quotas alors exemple on en a un
historique en europe et alors là c'est
on va on va s'adresser qu'aux gros
émetteurs donc le harceleur dont je
parlais tout à l'heure
ou bien un cimentier où il ya une
centrale électrique au charbon et à ce
moment ces gens là on va leur donner une
autorisation administrative des maîtres
ça a été les fameux droits pour la
rebaptiser sa droits à polluer mais en
fait c'est une autorisation
administrative
on leur dit bah voilà dans l'année vous
avez droit d'émettre temps et puis si
vous n'avez pas lu usage de tout ce que
vous avez le droit d'émettre
vous pouvez revendre ce que vous ce qui
vous sert à rien à quelqu'un d'autre qui
lui aura pas eu assez en termes de
droits d'émission et donc va avoir
besoin de se procurer auprès de
quelqu'un d'autre
un droit d'émission qui combat pas donné
au début c'est ça l'idée du système de
marché de quotas c'est que derrière vous
avez un marché en fait au début j'avais
les quotas puis derrière vous pouvez les
échanges et il ya un certain d'autres
endroits dans le monde où ce genre de
choses a été mis en place par exemple la
colombie britannique a mis ça en place
la chine est en train de mettre ça en
place de manière régionale mais avec des
avec un système de prix extrêmement bas
c'est donc après tout dépend de la
dureté de l'obligation si vous donnez
très peu de quotas ou jean-pierre vous
leur dites l'année prochaine vous aurez
la moitié de ce que vous avez envie
d'aller dernière c'est un peu plus
contraignant que si vous leur dites je
vais vous donner la même chose plus 5%
forcément bonjour propos jean marc
jancovici trois illustrations concrètes
des difficultés à mettre en place une
taxe carbone au canada
ici en europe mais d'abord en australie
où le débat justement très tendue a
refait surface cette semaine
le gouvernement libéral australien a
annoncé un réexamen de sa politique
climatique avec la volonté de faire
payer les entreprises du secteur de
l'énergie pour leurs émissions de co2
sauf qu'il abat encore une fois dû
reculer à melbourne
elodie d'argenton oui le gouvernement a
très vite reculé face aux critiques
crédits qui sont venus dans son propre
camp le sénateur corrie bernardi
notamment a fait le tour des télés pour
dénoncer un suicide économique l'une des
choses les plus stupides que j'aie
jamais entendue at il dit le débat est
donc de nouveau refermé il n'est plus
question de remettre en place une taxe
carbone le remettre en place parce que
pendant deux ans entre 2012 et 2014
les plus gros pollueurs devait payer une
taxe de 23 dollars australiens par tonne
carbone
sauf que ces pollueurs sont très
puissants en australie le secteur minier
le moteur de la croissance et les trois
quarts de l'électricité sont produits à
partir du charbon
l'ellure affirme régulièrement que ce
sont les consommateurs qui sont touchés
par la taxe carbone puisqu'ils doivent
payer des factures d'électricité plus
élevé
la question est si sensible que le
premier ministre malcolm turnbull
retourne sa veste après avoir plaidé
dans le passé pour fixer un prix au
carbone
il affirme désormais ne jamais avoir été
favorable à l'instauration d'une taxe
carbone
quoi qu'il en soit le gouvernement
assure que son contrat sera rempli qu'il
va réduire de 26 à 28 % ses émissions de
gaz à effet de serre d'ici 2030 par
rapport à 2005 sans taxe carbone mais
avec son système baptisé action directe
un système de subventions accordées aux
entreprises et aux agriculteurs qui
émettent moins de 100 mille tonnes de
co2 par an alors qu'au bord recevez-vous
jean marc jancovici cet exemple
australien exemple de bonne volonté
politique mais finalement insuffisante
il ya un grand malentendu en ce qui
concerne le changement climatique
c'est que l'on raisonne tous comme si
les ennuis étaient indéfiniment pour
plus tard donc on se dit en fait c'est
pas très grave que je refuse aujourd'hui
quelque chose qui va m'empêcher des
maîtres
on verra demain on sera jeu parce qu'en
fait c'est pire que ça c'est si je les
accepte je pense que ça va me gêner tout
de suite et si je n'accepte pas et bien
le monde va continuer comme avant et
pendant 35 ans mais actionnaires vont
recevoir de plus en plus d'argent je
vais embaucher de plus en plus de monde
et la croissance va continuer
or malheureusement c'est pas du tout
comme ça qu'il faut raisonner un moment
si le climat dérives trop par rapport à
ce qu'on a trouvé en entrant c'est à
dire l'état dans lequel il était en 1850
il va donc faire payer il a déjà
commencé les sécheresses au proche
orient ont un rôle direct dans ce qui
est en train de se passer en syrie
les sécheresses au maghreb ont eu un
rôle direct dans le déclenchement du
printemps arabe
donc le changement climatique il est
déjà en train de déstabiliser le monde à
nos portes
1 et l'idée qu'on va pouvoir continuer à
mettre plein de co2 dans l'atmosphère
sans ne jamais en payer le prix est une
illusion dangereuse
donc en fait il faut avoir un
raisonnement qui et comment est ce que
je suis inciter à faire des efforts il
sauf que mon métier d'être consultant je
m'adresse aux entreprises
je ne connais pas une entreprise je n'en
ai jamais rencontré une seule qui
innovent sans contrainte ça n'existe pas
donc l'idée laissez moi faire et je vais
m'occuper sérieusement tout sauf du
problème c'est mais c'est pas que ça ne
marche pas ça n'existe pas dues par la
contrainte peut s'appeler la confiance
les personnes qui font des choses que
vous avez innové la contrainte peut
s'appeler vos clients qui ont décidé que
ça les intéressait plus la contrainte
peut s'appeler l'état la joie gr au nom
de quoi une entreprise accepterait la
contrainte de ses concurrents et de ses
clients et jamais la contrainte de la
collectivité ou non je ne sais pas quoi
donc là en l'occurrence la contrainte de
monter progressivement le prix du
carbone est une contrainte très très
douce il faut bien comprendre que les
disruption dans le système provenant du
changement climatique seront beaucoup
plus violente
donc le en fait c'est cette asymétrie
qui causent le reçu c'est à dire que
tout le monde se dit bah si moi je fais
pas l'effort il va rien arriver de
particuliers et c'est très très
difficile de lutter contre cette idée
dans lequel l'australie là on voit bien
on a un gouvernement plutôt favorables à
la protection de l'environnement la
transition énergétique etc
alors imaginons un pays où les
dirigeants seraient prend pétrole et là
vous me voyez venir jean marc jancovici
qu'est-ce qui va qu'est ce qui peut se
passer avec donald trump à la maison
blanche à partir du 20 janvier
je vais répondre en dotant la première
c'est qu'en france on associe très
souvent le changement climatique au
pétrole
il faut savoir que dans le monde la
première source d'émissions de co2 c'est
pas le pétrole c'est le charbon les
seules centrales à charbon dans le monde
sont responsables de 20 % des émissions
planétaires de gaz à effet de serre
tougas confondues méthane protoxyde etc
les transports mondiaux c15 donc avant
même de parler du pétrole il faut
s'intéresser au charbon et ça à faire le
lien avec donald trump
parce que donald trump a dit qu'il
voulait relancer l'exploitation
charbonnière aux états unis sauf que ça
ne dépend pas de lui ça dépend d'un truc
qui s'appelle le prix du gaz la raison
pour laquelle les américains sont passés
du charbon au gaz dans la production
électrique
c'est ça essentiellement qui s'est passé
aux états unis et c'est ça qui a fait
faire faillite aux mines de charbon
américaine fait pire au tableau c'est le
gaz de schiste elle donc en gros il ya
une surproduction il ya toujours une
surproduction de gaz aux etats-unis à
cause du gaz de schiste
du coup le prix du gaz s'est effondré du
coup c'est pas rentable de continuer au
charbon et obama a volé au secours du
succès et il a eu raison
en faisant passer une réglementation de
l' agence de protection de
l'environnement américaine en disant il
sera interdit de construire une nouvelle
centrale à charbon en gros ceux des sacs
ça disait sa réglementation sauf que
personne n'a envie d'en construire
aujourd'hui parce que c'est absolument
pas rentable
donald trump pourra mettre sa menace
entre guillemets à exécution à la
condition que le prix du gaz remontent
et encore une fois ça ne dépend pas de
lui ça dépend d'autant moins de lui
qu'il a aussi dit qu'il voulait
favoriser la production de gaz donc il
peut par la fois favoriser la production
de gaz et avoir un prix du gaz élevée
qui ferait qui occasionnerait de retour
au charbon donc donald trump
moi j'attends de voir ce qui peut faire
de nuisibles trump c'est ne rien faire
ça c'est très clair mais il faut il faut
se rappeler qu'aux états unis les
pouvoirs du président sont
considérablement plus limité en terme de
politique intérieure une force
incroyable que ce que ça n'est le cas en
france
je veux dire le président ils maîtrisent
pas l'agenda parlementaire ils
maîtrisent pas ils maîtrisent pas grand
chose plutôt assureront ce que vous
dites finalement par rapport à tout ce
qu'on a pu entendre un depuis l'élection
de trump on passe de l'autre côté de la
frontière direction de canada
précisément où a donc était annoncé la
mise en place d'une taxe carbone dont
plusieurs provinces du pays et notamment
dans l'ouest
bonjour pascal gericke las en direct de
montréal bonjour michael
valeur comment les canadiens
accueille-t-il cet impôt pollution
puisqu'on dit sachez vous pascal en
alberta la province productrice de
pétrole une partie des citoyens a très
mal réagi à l'idée de devoir payer un
peu plus leur plein ou leur fac
ur de chauffage une manifestation pour
s'opposer à la taxe sur le carbone a
même eu lieu samedi
le prix fixé pour chaque tonne de gaz
carbonique reste pourtant très modeste
la première année le gouvernement a
prévu d'utiliser les sommes recueillies
en partie pour aider les pme à faire
face à la concurrence et aussi pour
baisser les impôts des albertains touché
de plein fouet par le chômage
d'autres provinces comme le québec et
l'ontario dans l'est n'ont pas attendu
pour limiter les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre que le gouvernement
central leur force la main déjà les deux
provinces participent à un marché des
échanges et à une bourse du carbone avec
la californie les entreprises doivent
limiter leurs émissions de gaz à effet
de serre celles qui n'y parviennent pas
à hachette des permis dont le prix varie
selon les enchères entre entreprises
polluantes et entreprises exemplaires
les sommes amassées permettra ensuite de
faciliter la transition énergétique vers
les ressources renouvelables bon est ce
que ces différentes mesures vont
permettre au canada de respecter les
engagements pris à paris lors de la cap
en 2015 le canada a promis de baisser
ses émissions polluantes de 30% d'ici
2030 un objectif plutôt modestes parce
que l'année de référence et 2005 une
période où la pollution au gaz
carbonique était déjà élevée malgré tout
les environnementalistes doute que le
canada parviennent à réduire
significativement ses gaz à effet de
serre dans un futur proche
côté positif c'est vrai le gouvernement
a annoncé la fermeture de plusieurs
centrales à charbon côté négatif par
contre l'industrie pétrolière prévoit
augmenter sa production
le pouvoir central vient en effet
d'autoriser la construction d'oléoducs
pour faciliter l'exportation de sables
bitumineux vers le port de vancouver
dans l'extrême ouest du pays
le prix du pétrole risque donc de
devenir plus intéressant pour les
producteurs qui vise les marchés
asiatiques
par contre cette énergie très polluante
à produire pourrait annuler l'effet des
réductions de gaz à effet de serre liées
à l'arrêt d'utilisation des centrales à
charbon
pascal gericke la correspondent de front
ce inter à montréal jean marc jancovici
pendant le petit papier de pascal on
vous sentez comme ça pas d'accord on va
dire oui toujours une affaire de prix le
coût de production d'un baril de pétrole
à partir des sables bitumineux dans
l'alberta
ce problème quelque part entre 60 et
plus de 100 dollars coûts de production
par baril avec un baril de pétrole
aujourd'hui à 50 dollars dans le monde
il n'y a pas un nouveau projet qui se
développera et c'est une très bonne
chose
soit dit en passant mais y'en a pas
nouveau c'est pas le fait de construire
un oléoduc qui va changer quoi que ce
soit la deuxième chose que je voudrais
rappeler c'est que il ya eu un incendie
à fort mcmurray
il ya quelques mois vous en souvenez
probablement en fait c'était c'était en
mai de l'année dernière sauf erreur de
ma part j'ai regardé quels étaient les
températures au canada juste avant le
déclenchement de l'incendié au mois de
mai le canada est quand même pas un pays
très très chaud normalement mais ça
dépassait les 30 degrés vous savez qu'en
ce moment près du cercle polaire on
dépasse de 20 degrés les normales le 1er
janvier 2016 il ne l'est pas au pôle
nord
c'est assez amusant que les canadiens
qui sont quand même en train de regarder
grandeur nature ce qui est en train de
se passer chez eux dont une partie de la
forêt est en train de dépérir ou a déjà
des péri à cause d'un secteur ravageur
qui sont favorisés par le réchauffement
disent qu'ils sont pas d'accord pour
prendre leur part à l'effort de quelque
chose qui doit juste sauvé une partie de
feu delà de leurs forêts et très
accessoirement d'autres choses dans leur
pays c'est à nouveau le haut mais
schizophrène dans cette histoire c'est à
dire que à huit heures du matin on va
dire faut sauver l'environnement et à 9
heures on est contre le fait de
contribuer à l'effort
la contribution à l'effort de la taxe
carbone elle a un inconvénient dont je
me suis rendu compte avec le temps c'est
qu'elle dit le prix alors qu'il ya
d'autres moyens d'obliger les gens à
agir qui ne disent pas le prix est en
fait qu'ils sont plus efficaces mais
j'aimerais justement qu'on parle de prix
jean marc jancovici
pourquoi ne réussit on pas à se mettre
d'accord sur un prix plancher un prix
plafond le même pour tous pour la tonne
de co2 parce que justement ça vous
permet de savoir ce que vous allez payer
donc si je vous oblige à acheter une
petite voiture par rapport à celle que
vous avez aujourd'hui vous savez pas
faire un rapide calcul très simple de ce
que ça vous coûte donc on prenait juste
que je vous y oblige quelques jours il
faut en fait si j'explicite le prix du
carbone qui est associé à cette mesure
je vais trouver des prix de quelques
centaines quelques milliers d'euros la
tonne mais sauf que personne va faire le
calcul
donc vous serez bon citoyen vous
achèterez une petite voiture si je rends
le prix explicite sert je vous dis je
vous allez droit d'acheter la voiture
que vous voulez mais juste vous allez
payer 500 euros la tonne de carbone et
ôté dessus m'étrangler mais sharp et
c'est parce que je vous ai dit le prix
est en fait la raison pour laquelle la
taxe carbone ça but j'ai fini par
comprendre sache un peu lent à mon âge
mais finit par comprendre ça alors que
j'ai été un grand prosélyte de la taxe
chute toujours mais je pense que ça
marchera pas à cause de ce que je viens
d'évoquer
c'est à dire que quand vous nommez la
peine vous dit combien
du coup les gens refusent alors que si
vous ne met pas la peine si vous dites
il est obligatoire de faire ceci ou de
faire cela et bien les gens ne calcule
pas le prix implicite qui est associé à
ça et du coup ça marche je sais pas si
on doit s'en réjouir ou pas on va
s'arrêter jean marc jancovici sur le
continent européen savoir quelle est la
politique européenne en la matière
bonsoir quentin dickinson en direct de
bruxelles
bonsoir michael est pour soir à tous bon
alors précisément quentin quelle est la
ligne de lui le cinéma une effective en
poser la question comme ça c'est y
répondre
en dépit de nombreuses tentatives la
ligne reste ici plutôt flou sinueuse et
incomplètes
chronologiquement la première déconvenue
d'ailleurs jean marc jancovici a fait
allusion tout à l'heure la première
déconvenue aura été celle du marché du
carbone destinée à pénaliser
financièrement les industries polluantes
problème le lancement on aurait été
complètement raté
puisque en pensant bien faire est en
quelque sorte pour amorcer la pompe un
nombre de permis de polluer bien trop
important été distribués et de ce fait
le marché a mis de longues années à
décoller encore reste-t-il aujourd'hui
très atone
même s'il couvrons bon an mal an dit-on
45 portion des émissions industrielles
de dioxyde de carbone dans lieu dans ce
domaine on constate tristement que plus
il est fait mention dans les discours
officiels de lutte contre les émissions
- on en voit dans les faits la
réalisation efficace c'est que les pays
membres sont d'accord sur les objectifs
de réduction mais chacun préfère en fait
que ce soit l'industrie du voisin qui en
fasse les frais à peine fixer des
objectifs de réduction sont contestés et
paraissent rapidement hors de portée par
la spécificité et le peu de l'ampleur
des moyens mis en oeuvre dans ce
contexte quentin quels sont les pays
locomotive est a contrario les derniers
wagons et bien comme on s'en doute les
locomotives qui ne fonctionne pas au
charbon d'ailleurs sont dans le nord de
l'europe
le précurseur on a dit tout à l'heure
c'est la suède qui applique sa taxe
carbone nationale depuis plus de 25 ans
suivie par ses voisins finlandais et
danois et dans un deuxième temps
surprise par le royaume uni et la
slovénie
et puis il ya la génération des années
2010 dont l'irlande et la france
quant aux wagons de queue libre à une
balle dans le sud de lieux et ce ne sont
pas nécessairement les plus grands qui
se montre les moins allants et puis il
ya le cas particulier de la pologne qui
continue à promouvoir contre vents et
marées les vertus supposées du charbon
dans ce pays qu'on servi damman encore
d'importantes réserves en deux mots
quentin pour finir les objectifs de
l'union européenne pour 2020
eh bien ce sont où ce ne sont que des
objectifs des objectifs 10 20 20 20 en
2020 dans l'union européenne
la consommation d'énergie devra avoir
baissé de 20% par rapport au chiffre de
1990 les énergies renouvelables devront
représenter 20% de la consommation
totale et l'efficacité énergétique devra
avoir progressé de deviner 20%
mais les spécialistes ici tiennent déjà
ses ambitions d'ailleurs relativement
modeste pour irréalisable
quentin dickinson en direct de bruxelles
merci beaucoup irréalisable jean marc
jancovici
on a en ce qui concerne l'europe
essayez d'utiliser le seul chausse-pied
qu'on avait à disposition
l'europe n'a pas de compétences en
matière fiscale la fiscalité reste du
domaine des états donc une taxe carbone
européenne c'est pas possible
donc l'europe a fait la seule chose
qu'elle sait faire c'est réglementé des
quantités parce que ça elle a le droit
de prendre des décisions à la majorité
qualifiée alors que prendre des
décisions fiscales c'est l'unanimité
c'est la raison pour laquelle l'europe a
mis en place un marché outre le fait que
l'europe est d'inspiration très libérale
on va dire très instruments de marchés
d'une manière générale et l'europe ne
sait pas se dire que la croissance se
terminera un jour
donc l'europe résonne toujours en
croissance perpétuelle et ce qui s'est
passé à ce moment c'est qu'au moment où
on a mis en place les autorisations
choisi le logiciel et on a mis en place
des autorisations d'émettre en dix ans
les industriels vont produire de plus en
plus toujours forever donc au moment où
leur donne les premières allocations on
tient compte du fait qu'ils vont faire
plus d'acier plus de ciment etc puisque
c'est normal que c'est comme ça que ça
doit se passer
patatras harry la crise de lehman
brothers la production industrielle
européenne commence à descendre en fait
c'est un contraction énergétique subi en
europe qui est à l'origine de ça et du
coup il se met pas plus ils émettent
moins
donc effectivement on se retrouve sur à
louer avec un prix de marché qui s'est
cassé la figure
o'shea project on a milité pour un prix
de réserve c'est à dire vous n'avez pas
le droit d'acheter une tonne en dessous
de tels prix et faire monter ce prix
dans le temps ce qui revient à
transformer ça en quasi taxes et à à
bruxelles on nous a dit dans dans le
marché marche très bien
une dernière dernière question jean marc
jancovici réponse en une minute
on a compris grâce à vous j'ai tech sa
taxe carbone n'est pas là la panacée
quel autre type de taxe pourrait tout
mettre en place pour aller davantage
vers vers une économie dite bas carbone
faut réglementer en fait aujourd'hui il
falloir deux choses qui vont faire un
peu froid dans le dos les deux degrés de
l'accord de paris c'est une division par
trois je dis bien par 3 des émissions
planétaires d'ici à ce que mes enfants
et mon âge
en 35 ans voire par trois il est
strictement impossible d'y arriver avec
une taxe carbone parce que le temps
qu'on se mette d'accord on est déjà mort
donc en fait maintenant il faut passer
par la voie réglementaire donc sur la
performance des bâtiments il faut
réglementer des bâtiments existants a
pas des bâtiments à construire cela
c'est un faux problème
en ce qui concerne la consommation des
véhicules il faut passer par la voie
réglementaire
en ce qui concerne les émissions de
l'industrie il faut passer par la voie
réglementaire
si on ne fait pas ça il ya zéro chance 0
que l'on tienne l'accord de paris ses
parents courageux vous dites moi je sais
pas si on a bien fait de vous inviter
jean marc jancovici merci merci beaucoup
spécialiste de la transition énergétique
entre autres fondateur du cabinet de
conseil carbone 4
dans un instant au par tirage